maybe you're all wondering why we're
including so many foreign cities in a
Rasta party and the truth is all of us
in show business are part of one big
family and part of our family is in
London right now having a very British
late-night supper at the very ritzy Ritz
Hotel on Piccadilly and they're waiting
to announce the award for art direction
and there are good friends Glenn Close
and mr. Mel Gibson
Thank You Billy and greetings from Great
Britain whose movie industry has given
us more Academy Award winners than any
country outside the United States Glenn
and I are honored to present the first
Academy Award ever given on this side of
the Atlantic or outside of Southern
California for that matter it's the
award for art direction of course Mel
and I are not just here to enjoy
ourselves so it is very amusing watching
your wonderful audience struggling to
stay awake at 3:30 in the morning
we're actually here in England to
rehearse a movie version of William
Shakespeare's Hamlet one of his other
scripts happens to be nominated for Best
Picture this year Henry the fifth yeah I
think bill is probably a dead certainty
for Best Original Screenplay next year
later music but tonight we're here to
honor the art directors art art
directors a men and women whose vision
and imagination contain a director's
dream into reality and turn everyday
reality into fantasy in case you're
wondering how we're going to make the
award in London Price Waterhouse has
dispatched couriers around the world
with little locked boxes containing
sealed envelopes and representative is
standing by here at the risk I mean Rick
Ritz Hotel
with our sealed envelope and its
containing probably the best-kept secret
in Britain you know apart from the name
of Fergie's new baby girl the nominees
for the best achievement in art
direction are for the abyss art
direction by Leslie dilly set decoration
by and kujan for The Adventures of Baron
Munchausen art direction Dante Ferretti
set decoration by Prince Eska lo Schiavo
art direction by Anton Furst set
decoration by Peter Young
for Driving Miss Daisy art direction by
Bruno Ribeiro set decoration by crispy
and Salas
and for glory art direction by Norman
Garwood set decoration by Garrett Lewis
maybe we have the envelope please taking
out of the box
thank you right and the Oscar goes to
Anton Furst for Batman decoration be the
young
being so Jack Nicholson I love it
yes great he made my sets look so small
to Tim obviously to John and Peter for
their incredibly competent and wonderful
spirit for the producing of it and to
the bat gang you know the a1 team I work
with but this is mine anyway Peters over
there P Nayyar
oh yeah
you have no idea how happy I am the
satellite worked
from world-class athlete to worldwide
box-office star please welcome a man who
has a bigger chest than Madonna
ladies and gentlemen mr. Arnold
Schwarzenegger
good evening ladies and gentlemen when I
was a wide-eyed little kid growing up in
Europe I fell in love with American
movies I never dreamed it one day I will
be making them myself here in Hollywood
and they will be distributed all over
the world but in but here tonight I feel
right at home because Hollywood is one
big completely international family come
Aldens family comes from kaliesha
yugoslavia hill crystals family comes
from odessa russia and i was born in
grads austria in the five films
nominated for Best Picture this year
also reflected that international flavor
two of them were directed best Raelians
one of them been Irishmen I wonder how
two Americans managed to get in there
and to introduce you to the first of
this films we have a young lady whose
family was part Cherokee Indian and
parts me Swedish talking about the
smartest blog and this lovely result is
the beautiful talented Miss Kim Basinger
thank you and hello the world we we've
got five great films here and they're
great for one reason because they tell
the truth
but there is one film missing from this
list that deserves to be on it because
ironically it might tell the biggest
truth of all and that's do the right
thing yes yes yeah
okay so on to business
so first up well I saw this movie and I
fell in love with it at a very special
time in my life - about a professor at a
strict all-boys school the defies his
superiors and teaches his kids to do
their own right thing but I really like
this ad that I saw in the paper it says
it makes you cry it makes you laugh and
it makes you care what more could there
be
Dead Poets Society